and then talk a little bit about uh one
of the things that i think investors
are scared of but also some investors
are excited about is the premiums
on uh the various funds so for those
that don't know
uh basically a premium is when the fund
itself holds a certain amount of assets
let's say a million dollars worth of an
asset but it's actually trading at a
value above that so it could be 1.1 1.2
million dollars
that delta between where is trading and
the actual asset value
is a premium at times there's uh certain
vehicles you guys have that have
you know almost no premium right kind of
five ten percent tech premiums
all the way up to i think the ether
trust at one point uh i saw i had like
an 800
premium and so kind of just talk a
little bit about how you guys think of
the premiums and
across the different assets uh as well
sure yeah let's so let's step back for a
minute
so you know if if someone is an
accredited investor
um you know they can buy any one of the
grayscale products
directly from us at net asset value
now so far um four out of the ten
grayscale
products have been approved for a public
quotation so that's our bitcoin product
um the ethereum product ethereum classic
product as well as the grayscale digital
large
cap fund and so it's important for me to
reiterate here
that grayscale does not trade in we're
not market makers we're not dictating
the price
at which any of the four products i just
mentioned are trading in the public
market
on any given day uh instead these
products are
really driven by market demand and
market sentiment
um and so i think today the price at
which these products trade
in the market is really being driven by
a couple of factors
i think one there is today very very
very few
if any um access products for digital
currency
and so as an investor if you're
typically used to having a brokerage
account an ira whatever it may be
and you're used to accessing stocks
bonds etfs mutual funds etc
through that platform well now you can
also get yourself digital currency
exposure
through any one of the grayscale
products that are that are publicly
traded
um and so there is kind of an ease of
use so liquidity
um and then it also negates the need for
investors to navigate
buying transferring holdings storing
safekeeping you know digital currency
directly
and i think one of the other big areas
where we see a lot of uses
of the grayscale products is also in
retirement accounts
so we do not only have investors who
want to
make these allocations for the medium to
long term but they want to do so in a
tax efficient way
and so they look to deploy investments
in greyscale products inside
iras and roth iras and 401ks
and so we're not only facilitating that
in our private placements which we do
for investors often
but also on the public market as well
and so again if you have one of those
types of accounts but you're restricted
to solely buying publicly listed
equities or bonds or etfs
um well then you really would have a
very difficult time
buying bitcoin directly in that kind of
an account or buying ethereum directly
in that kind of account
so there again um you know having the
grayscale product
really is providing a value to investors
and giving them the ability to get
exposure whereas
they otherwise would not be able to yeah
it's really interesting
and i guess as part of this uh maybe
talk a little bit about
where you see most of the inflows is it
in the public markets or is it in those
private placements
yes so the inflows that we get are only
into the private placements themselves
so investors who are accredited and who
are buying the private placements from
us
their liquidity option is selling into
the public market
after they've held their shares for a
statutory
uh amount of time in the case of bitcoin
that's only six months
because that is an sec reporting company
in the case of some of our other
products that are publicly quoted
that's actually a 12-month period so
inflows really only come into
the prime the private placement on the
secondary market over time what we've
seen and what we believe will continue
to see
is that the volume and the number of
shares in the public market
will grow over time as more and more
investors who bought on the primary side
have their shares roll off into the
secondary market
and obviously when people hear inflows
they think okay what about outflows how
do you think about outflows and
how do you measure that if at all sure
so we actually don't offer redemption
programs in our products
so the grayscale products um
you know have these ongoing private
placements where we're taking inflows
and then
the liquidity option is actually to move
your shares out onto the public market
after that holding period
versus a traditional um you know
creation redemption process where
actually the share count
could in theory be lowered and the
underlying assets sold
um that is not in fact the case inside
our products but rather the
assets raised just roll off into the
secondary market and continue to be a
part of the products
one of the things that uh people have
talked a lot about over the years is a
bitcoin etf
uh you guys obviously have the closest
thing to that
a little bit different
what are you guys thinking about or or
kind of paying attention to in terms of
that etf
uh process and then uh maybe a potential
approval at some point
sure so we think a bitcoin etf
is a matter of when not a matter of if
um i think you know the regulators have
done
a fantastic job of staying ahead of the
curve on the digital currency asset
class as a whole
pomp you know you spend a lot of your
time trying to stay on top of what's
going on in the ecosystem
i do myself at times it almost seems
untenable
um because of how fast the asset class
is evolving and moving
day to day week by week um we like to
sometimes
say you know um a week in the digital
currency world is like six months in the
real world
um and you know i think with that being
said
our regulators have recognized digital
currency bitcoin in particular
in a lot of ways that lend a lot of
validation to it and should really
in our opinion not be deterrent for
investors accessing
the asset class so you know we've gotten
guidance from the irs we've gotten
guidance from the sec we've gotten
guidance from the cftc
um you know the grayscale bitcoin trust
is now an sec reporting company so
they've taken a really proactive
approach and there are in fact ways
to work with regulators um on the asset
class within existing frameworks
but they're just not ready to approve an
etf yet and i think that they've been
pretty explicit about wanting to see
certain dynamics within the market
mature a little bit more
things like you know maybe a more global
order book for bitcoin maybe things like
surveillance sharing agreements
um maybe a little bit more regulation
and oversight
of the different marketplaces and venues
where digital assets are being traded
and you know i think that that's
something that certainly we as a firm
and me as an individual
i'm excited to kind of see how the
ecosystem continues to mature
i've been in the space now you know
seven years and it's amazing to see how
much progress
has been made so i think again it's
going to be a matter of when not a
matter of if
and investors just need to be patient um
but luckily in the meantime
there's tons and tons of ways for
investors to access digital currency
directly um through futures through
grayscale products
through all kinds of means um in order
to participate in the asset class now
and not have to wait for an etf as an
etf
eventually gets approved right when you
say kind of when not if uh
what would be the potential impact on
your business or kind of what would you
guys do differently
uh when that day comes sure so you know
i do think that it's worth noting that
in 2017 we were working to move the
grayscale bitcoin trust
up to the new york stock exchange as an
etf
and while we made a lot of great
progress with the sec we ultimately
pulled out of that process recognizing
that they again just weren't ready for
it
um and so i do think that there will be
a time eventually
where um you know this product is able
to hopefully one day
um you know be able to achieve that that
level of registration and change
that product structure and eventually we
hope to be able to turn
you know the entire product family into
etfs but we're only you know 10
12 years into the life cycle uh of the
of the asset class and again i think we
just need to be patient
but you know we'll certainly be there
when our regulators are ready for it
and uh you know try and stay on top of
those conversations as much as we can